welcome back everybody new year means
new goals and for many of us
john especially after the past few
months it is to get in shape
and yes absolutely true alex and since
many of you at home and certainly i
right now working from home
there are some limits on gyms and people
might be lost on
where to get started when you want to
leave the house and try and get back in
shape
bianca holman is live this morning at
game changers sports gym
with a personal trainer to give us some
insight bianca good morning i understand
you've got quite
the quite the left cross
hey yeah oh you saw me on the punching
bag huh so i tried to get a little
get my rocky on you know get my rocky
balboa on for a quick second there
but yeah i'm here with willy who is the
master trainer here
at game changers sports gym so tell me
you know for people who don't feel
comfortable maybe going into the gym or
maybe they do and they're doing classes
what can people do at home to still get
an upper body workout and everybody
workout
well today during our super fit class
we're going to focus on the upper body
training
and these are exercises you can do in
the gym at home
and hotel rooms anywhere you do you can
do it everywhere
everywhere this is a vocal ball right
here right now she's working on core
training keeping the core nice and tight
and right now that whole effort is going
through a whole over body keeping our
triceps typing that chest tight
and letting the ball work her core
what's regal doing here is going side to
side
using our arms and shoulders keeping the
chest tight again working the core
because without the core
nothing works and so you're actually
using your body weight you have to use
your body weight trust me without waste
all right and again if you don't have a
bosu ball you can just get on the ground
and hold a body plank to keep your body
nice and tight and for us ladies we want
to get rid of the bat wings we want to
get rid of
the bat wings and this is right here you
can work the triceps by doing dips
you can use a chair you can use the side
of a couch you can use anything
let's go up and down keep the cord nice
and tight and use your own body weight
to work on those floppy arms
right and then jen is going to come over
here and the back is what women really
want to work in the back right
sure you can use popsicle cans you can
use anything in the house
and just do renegade rolls again keeping
the cord nice and tight
pulling through the shoulders and
working her back right here looks good
and then what about the regular push-ups
and the regular push-up we like to do it
off the bolster ball because it's
ability training
but you can do push-ups off the ground
on your knees you can do them anywhere
because if this is your new year's
resolution the thing is just get up and
do it do it
don't just sit home just say i'm gonna
do it you can do this anywhere you can
do it on a commercial
doing a commercial just say i mean this
is a one-minute training session
just get up and do it yeah you know just
get going get going
well we definitely need that
encouragement and for people who they're
thinking about going into the gym
because i know gyms are doing a lot to
keep people safe
you got to wear your match just like
these people are doing social distancing
i understand you all have some equipment
just like other gyms to help sanitize
things yeah you know once
everybody's done they sweat it over
everything we normally wipe everything
down
but we do have the sanitation done to
keep everything nice and clean
like you see on airplanes and airports
and everywhere yeah so we keep the jig
100
clean so we try and keep those guys out
of here yeah
thank you well good stuff well thank you
so much willie for explaining this you
know again
that gyms are doing things to make sure
that people are staying safe sanitizing
it all down yes and so many things that
you can do whether it's at the gym
or at your home or in your hotel room
it's just getting fit and getting moving
all right good stuff we're gonna send it
back to you guys in the studio
oh that's good stuff those people are
like thank goodness you can stop
doing these exercises
you know alex i always feel like and
bianca and the trainer
pointed out the the important thing is
it's just the mind over matter like
getting up and actually doing it
i can't tell you how many times during
the pandemic and maybe you at home are
the same way
you're sitting on the couch and you know
you should do something
but it's a matter of actually like
turning on the engine actually doing it
and so hopefully this and and bianca and
her friend there
are motivation to actually get up and
actually start doing stuff yes well we
all know we certainly have time